[00:07:22] This next story has absolutely
exploded and it's as detailed as it is disgusting
as we're discussing today.
A whole bunch of companies are working on
Corona virus vaccine.
That's a good thing.
One of the companies is a German medical company
named Cure však.
There are now widespread reports with corroboration
that Donald Trump offered a billion dollars
to this company to secure the vaccine for
the United States.
Only now the reaction from Trump.
This was totally predictable.
First, they denied it was true.
Fake news, fake news, fake news.
Oh, it's been confirmed by German officials
and authorities.
Well, they said good for Trump.
He's watching out for us, America first, which
is exactly what you would imagine a Trump
bist would say about this.
So let's go through the details.
Trump was interested in buying this future,
a possible vaccine for the United States for
a billion dollars.
This became known inside of Germany to the
point that the German government was almost
negotiating against Trump, offering money
to the company so that the vaccine would stay
in Germany and be available to everyone as
it should be.
If and when it is ready to go.
Germans were understandably outraged.
The world is understandably outraged.
Trump wanted to get the vaccine here and only
here somehow to help him politically.
That's what this is about.
That's what Donald Trump was trying to do.
Now, of course, U.S. officials can't deny
the story because it's been corroborated so
widely.
What they're saying is it's been misreported.
For example, U.S. officials are saying we're
talking to lots of companies who are working
on vaccines and we can offer money to them
to help them.
Of course, that's not what this what this
is.
And any solution that is found, they say,
should be shared with the world.
What they're not saying is, would it be shared
with the whole world at the same time or would
the United States get it first?
The giving Trump the opportunity to announce,
I got us the vaccine.
Americans are getting vaccinated before anybody
else.
Now, adding to the intrigue here, last week,
this company, Cure však, weirdly announced
they were changing CEOs.
This was an unusual CEO, Daniel Many Kela
was replaced by Ingmar Horror.
Just weeks after many Kela met with Donald
Trump.
The hypothesis is and again, this part is
more speculative.
The hypothesis is that many Kela may actually
have been willing to accept the billion dollars
from Trump to give the vaccine only, or at
least first to the United States.
The board and stockholders of Cure však caught
wind of it, fired the guy, put in a different
CEO and said very clearly, if we are successful
in developing a vaccine, it should help and
protect the entire world.
The German Health Minister Spon.
Said that a takeover of cure back by the Trump
administration is, quote, off the table.
That cure vac will only develop a vaccine
for the whole world, not for individual countries.
Look at where the world is today.
Donald Trump offering cash.
To give him the vaccine, to let him get the
benefit.
And of course, after denying that this happened.
His supporters predictably started saying,
hey, this is good trumps president of the
United States.
Trump is not president of Italy.
Trump is not president of Germany.
His first priority should be get us the vaccine.
But of course, this is as immoral as it is
stupid.
The disease didn't start in the US yet we
are now increasingly ravaged by it.
Vaccinating only Americans wouldn't help.
Since no vaccine is 100 percent effective.
Not everyone would get the vaccine and the
disease would simply keep spreading.
If only Americans were vaccinated.
This is aside from this being utterly disgusting,
it's also very, very short sighted.
This is that that's sort of dumb.
America first mentality.
That's not only immoral, but it's also idiotic
in this case.
And as I read this, I realized, you know,
if Trump wasn't born to a rich family, instead
of trying to buy a vaccine for a billion bucks
from Germany, he'd be the guy buying the hand
sanitizer in order to start price gouging
by then selling it at 30 or 40 bucks a pop.
Understand that Germans are shocked and appalled
by this.
People in Germany can't understand how is
Trump even a person that exists in the world?
Never mind.
How is he president of the United States?
And sadly, these low information Trump ists
who see him as unable to do any wrong say
love it, go Trump.
Make America great again, keep America great
again.
It's a nightmare hellscape of embarrassment
made worse every day.
And just to put a final point on this, imagine
for a second the reverse situation.
Imagine a pandemic was spreading all over
the world and it turned out that a U.S. company
had a vaccine ready to go.
And imagine that the U.S. company sold rights
to the vaccine, too.
I don't know Italy or Germany or France or
China or Russia or whoever.
And maybe later they'd make it available to
Americans, the same people who are saying
don't regulate businesses.
And what a good job Trump is doing.
Trying to get us the vaccine would be saying,
take over that business, put the executives
in prison.
It is a disgusting double standard.
It's truly a stunning story.
And my guest is over the next few days, we'll
learn a lot more about the details.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter for
all the latest cobia 19 updates.
[00:13:09][346.9]
[00:13:10] A lot is happening on my Twitter
account at the Packman.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this.
[00:13:15][5.0]
[351.9]